(bright music)
- Wilderness areas are
incredibly important,
because we need to have
at least a few areas
that we can go and feel like
we're still connected somehow to nature.
The wonderful thing is, it's
land that we can all share
and we can all use,
and not one person owns it.
And so, you can come out and feel like
you kind of own it for the day.
(upbeat music)
Vermilion Cliffs National Monument
is on the Arizona-Utah border.
It encompasses 300,000
acres for public use.
You can go for days
exploring the back country
and finding all kinds of new discoveries.
My first job with BLM was back in 2000.
I was stationed at a remote site
out in the middle of all this,
and I fell in love with it
and didn't want to leave.
I feel like my job is to
help educate the public
to protect places like this.
Vermilion Cliffs is most iconically known
for the wave.
It is gorgeous.
It is an undulating slick rock sandstone,
but the wave is not the only feature
in this beautiful country.
There are so many other things to explore
if you're willing to make the effort.
(lively piano music)
White Pocket requires
incredible commitment
to get here.
Skills to navigate some pretty tough roads
and you're dealing with a lot
of Mother Nature's worst elements.
Getting here is a big reward.
I'm free out here.
A lot of us kind of scratch our heads
because we don't understand
how a landscape like this can be formed,
but all of these things
are shaped by Mother Nature
over about 190 million years.
And so it's pretty
incredible and fascinating
to marvel at how long it's taken
to create this great sculpture.
The beauty of this place,
you can't compare it to anything else.
(digital jingle)